but then it gets extreme when like
people are mad at lizzo for going on a
diet and she's not even losing weight
they're just mad she's dieting she's
eating vegetables
everybody know who this is
only because I saw the computer screen
Rebel Wilson oh she lost weight Rebel
Wilson what do you mean they'll save me
yeah
she said I saw the name already dude pay
attention to the side of the table
everybody be yelling all right you just
you just said
you are absolutely right good job
everybody clap the bar Rebel Wilson
Rebel Wilson give me a medal she doesn't
seem like the same person anymore uh-oh
because I'm so used to seeing her fat
that's a hot take oh man I'm going
straight there but it's like I mean I
mean we all do this to celebrities right
like like you gotta preserve them at
that age and what you've liked them for
and all that that's like why Jonah Hill
was so depressed because he got skinny
you got skinny people were like oh
you're not funny anymore yeah you
probably you lost roles too yeah
straight up right because uh it says
Rebel Wilson says that Pitch Perfect
contract had a clause in it that she
couldn't lose weight yeah I mean it's
her character I mean I understand that
if they're casting you as if you're
supposed to be a fat person I mean she
was fat Amy yeah yeah that was her name
right one of the storyline is that like
she lost a bunch of weight or something
I mean wouldn't it be the same thing if
they were casting a [__] meth guy and
he gained weight yep like it would be
the same same thing yeah don't get fat
yeah what if what if simu got a belly he
can't be he can't be yeah it's true you
can't lose your abs but that's not okay
though that's not okay it's not okay
fat you can just get fat but then it
gets extreme when like people are mad at
lizzo for going on a diet and she's not
even losing weight they're just mad
she's dieting she's eating vegetables
that's like crazy that's nuts like the
amount of like fat phobia and fat
shaming but also like skinny shaming
like why are you trying to lose weight
like are you not comfortable but it's
like I mean even with me and I have
never been on like the level that Rebel
Wilson is on or anything but it's like
you know she's like famous famous but
the amount of people like commenting
lose weight someone even commented I was
talking about my bulimia growing up and
they were like it looks like you need to
be bulimic for another few weeks or
something like that and it's like but
then when I do get really skinny people
are like why did you lose weight or like
why did you do this and it's like even
the pressure just from my and I don't
have like a big platform like her like
it [__] with you yeah you can't win
yeah right
because some guys like skinny and some
guys like thick so don't you'll never
win and the like what happened to Adele
too when Adele lost weight people were
like they got mad at her what I don't
get is so for them they're singers right
they're supposed to be known for their
voice and then their music so why the
[__] does anyone care if they got a peg
leg or not I think it's like a thing
where like if you it's internalized yeah
it's like if you're overweight and you
see yourself in like you're like oh
that's my hero because they're
overweight and they did this and then
they lose weight it's like oh [__] come
on we can't be fat together yeah it's
like kind of a peg leg homies there
there's there's a weird thing about that
right um it's like uh that they maybe
are your hero not just because you see
yourself in them but because you uh
it's okay to not be this like amazing
Hollywood figure yeah they look at it
like a victory yeah you know what I mean
it's kind of like okay the world is
becoming a better and more inclusive
place and then the second you fall into
that same trap and become exactly what
you know what I mean you you're kind of
stood up against it's like you're you're
a hypocrite for it like Meghan Trainor
hell remember Meghan Trainor's breakout
single was about like being okay that
you're like bigger no it's all about the
bass it's all the bass like no yeah yeah
yeah oh so that allegory is basically
like you know if you're heavy it's fine
love you it's all about loving yourself
and [__] and then when she lost weight
people are like you're turning on your
own brand I don't which I don't get
because it's like she's not telling
anyone to be skinny she's not telling
anyone to like she's saying love
yourself for as you are and it's like a
lot of the time if like I had a lot of
trouble losing weight for a while
because I had mold poisoning so as soon
as that's a big thing to have yeah and
like as soon as I tackle the mold
poisoning it was easier to lose weight
once my anxiety was under control it was
easier to lose weight it's not like I'm
over here being like I can only eat this
much a day and that's how I'm losing
weight but it's like a lot of people
just when they get healthier it just
naturally shuts off and it's like why
are you telling them they can't love
themselves or like that they're BR like
it's just [__] up sure and it's like
so many people way too involved in other
people's lives who are no one's saying
that who's secure with their own bodies
right exactly I don't know if um this
topic really works for guys though
because like we don't really have a
movement of like body positivity yeah
like it's just if you fat and then you
you got skinnier you got fit I think the
reaction is much more different maybe I
could probably see it from the gay
community but like I don't know I don't
I remember when David got skinny people
like oh I miss fat David because we like
laughing at him yeah that's not because
of like he inspires me because I'm a fat
man you know like I don't know they if
he loses weight I I heard I I heard
things where people get inspired fat
dudes get inspired because he loses
weight and now they can do it too dude
perfect from like stay fat because I'm
fat which is what I'm seeing from from
the female that's true that's true we've
got to be fat together whereas like with
David it's like well if your fat lazy
ass can do it then my fat lazy ass can
do it too yeah that's true David became
the David Goggins of the weight loss
community of the fat Community I forgot
how fat he was until like you would post
like older uh reels oh yeah and I'm like
oh [__] David was big yeah I did I did
get kind of checked by that recent
classic JK reel that rhymes I didn't
recognize him for a sec I think it's
it's just different because we're not
judged for our looks the way that women
are like it's way more hardcore and in
the way that that I see in girls
comments the way they talk [__] to each
other too it's way different we talk
[__] on skill or like you're you can't
play this well or whatever but very it's
or we roast each other for being fat but
it's a different kind of it doesn't
sting this it's like when you see like a
Hollywood actor who used to have like a
six-pack and now they have like a dad
bod you're like oh they got a dad bod
but you don't like shame them for it
you're not like man you lost your brand
it's crazy it's over okay so women do
[__] on women a little gnarly but like
the way men [__] on a woman oh it is
like the craziest thing I've ever seen
like woman might just say to me you're
embarrassing which okay I know but like
men are like you don't think you deserve
to be raped what I've gotten oh my at
least a thousand of those comments
because that's just in cell crazy it's
like that's crazy man like men are the
ones telling me like you should continue
being bulimic or someone said oh yeah uh
no one wants a hippo like you or it's
just like all this crazy woman don't go
that crazy like women are like if you
look at woman's posts where women are
commenting they're like slay where did
you get your top baby like just stuff
like that but mango ham for no reason
yeah there's a lot of psychotic [__]
dudes but I feel like in general late
like females on social media just get
more [__] in general from guys and girls
yeah like like we're laughing about it
like I was like dude I haven't had a
death threat in a minute miss having one
like all the time and they don't you
don't even do any content that's
controversial I'm the one that's saying
[__] that's controversial and the last
time someone wrote to me and wanted to
kill me I wrote back and I said let's
meet up
so I'm like I don't know
um it's just a different world I think
yeah but Bart did mention that it's
funny because our fans
are scared of like doing it doing
something
how did you say you worded it where like
it was like usually people have fans
that the fans aren't scared of them or
something like that
you worded it by saying something like
you're not a normal person no no but you
were talking about
I know I'm not a normal [__] person
but he was talking about in the group
chat he said something about other so
like let's say like someone out there
who's a who's who's an influencer right
they're afraid of their fan base
oh yeah yeah and I think our fans they
know we're armed and they know that
we'll shoot them so it's a little bit
different that's true that's true that's
true yeah yeah yeah it's different yeah
yeah so I was like I was thinking about
the text part where he was talking about
how Joe's on a different Universe yeah
exactly yeah
seemed like it would matter
yeah like a lot of people they they're
uh they're actually scared of their fan
base so it feels like extra pressure
yeah whereas from us we're not and then
so it we don't we also don't feel it as
much I think wow so you guys are
gangsters that's what you're telling me
reformed we're just happy people
but it is harder for girls like the
history of of women like famous women
being like stop killed by a fatter yeah
way [__] higher I do think that
because like like let's say the same guy
that might talk [__] to hers right yeah
they might look at us as big brother so
it's a different dining it's a different
yeah yeah so they're not here like like
I want to murder these guys it's more
like I want to be your friend and then
they'll talk [__] to girls yeah so I
think it's it's a different feeling they
want to terrorize yeah even though it's
the same person it's just same person
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah not our
fans though so I'll start posting with
you guys all the time hey you want to
[__]
we have good people now though it's
really great all the girls that have
been on here though for the most part
they're like your fans are the [__]
coolest what when they end up yeah
following and all that and yeah yeah
it's because we have like normal folks
you know yeah you know what's crazy is I
went on this one podcast I won't say
what it is but you can probably easily
find it first thing they said to me was
like I thought you were plus size based
off your Instagram but you're actually
skinny in real life whoa they said wait
they verbally said that to you as a host
yeah like it's an intro yeah yeah
what is that oh there's no social cue
filter how do you answer that afterwards
he was like the camera really does add
10 pounds on you and I was like oh there
you go that's a compliment I didn't know
there was a podcast for Love on the
Spectrum
I only used to think you were obese but
in real life you're not saying that [__]
that's [__] weird it was so
here I was coming feeling confident he's
like yeah you look like your plus size
on Instagram but in real like you
actually look [__] hot I'm like oh
this sounds like that sounds like a like
a pickup artist negging technique yeah
these guys it's good it does sound like
a classic night it sounds like someone's
teaching him to say [__] like that he is
known online for saying the most like
controversial like not great [__] so
it's like actually but he's probably
yeah getting those clips because it's a
tactic oh I see you know just doing
something saying something really wild
and then like boom actually I never even
watched the podcast back because I'm
like I don't want to like listen to a
fact but if he cut it out I don't know
oh he cut it out I don't know I haven't
watched it because I don't wanna I
didn't want to listen to him maybe he
cut it out and then posted just that
snippet yeah yeah that's the preview
[Music]